jahrzehntelang waren ausländische
arbeitskräfte in der schweiz wohl
gelitten haben zum wohlstand dieses
landes beigetragen
jetzt ist schluss damit jetzt herrscht
stillstand in der schweiz
der folgende bericht ist ein
gedankenspiel
er beschreibt eine fiktive situation die
nahe zukunft realität werden könnte
es schneit
doch der schnee wird die misere der
schweizer tourismusbranche nicht retten
hotels sind leer beschlossen kein
personal für die gäste luxus in leeren
hallen ein land in der krise
der öffentliche verkehr erlahmt keine
spur mehr von dichte stress dramatisch
ist die situation auf den baustellen
weil heerscharen ausländische
arbeitskräfte das land verlassen haben
die schweiz sieht hilflos zu die
massenauswanderung ist dauerthema in den
medien
kein ende der krise in sicht nach
aufkündigung der bilateralen verträge
durch die eu reagiert panik in bern
denn auch die massenauswanderung von
ausländern zurück in ihre
herkunftsländer zeigt immer
dramatischere folgen
von den ursprünglich acht millionen
einwohnern der schweiz kamen 18 5
millionen aus dem ausland
davon haben inzwischen 14 4 millionen
der schweiz den rücken gekehrt
grund für die auswanderung ist der
ökonomische aufschwung in vielen
heimatländern von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund in indien und sri
lanka beispielsweise boomt die
it-branche auf dem balkan hat dank eu
hilfe die industrie einen enormen
aufschwung genommen
grund genug vor allem für jüngere
ausländer sich neu zu orientieren
jetzt hat sich beim umschwung war jetzt
im bus leer wirtschaftlich hochschule
stattgefunden hat ich fühle mich wieder
die option hofgang ein rückzieher und
peter besucht bis 9
die parteien streiten darüber wie es zu
dieser entwicklung kommen konnte
die svp bereit ihre jahrelang
ausländerfeindliche politik
alt bundesrat blocher zum blick so war
das nie gemeint die weltwoche sieht ihre
mission erfüllt sie titelt endlich die
schweiz ist wieder die schweiz
endlose diskussion unter den linken über
die verfehlte politik alles gewusst
nichts getan schreibt die biz
bund und kantone sehen dem phänomen der
massenauswanderung hilflos zu
so schlimm die schweiz in die größte
krise ihrer geschichte
auch ich verlassen und das land das war
mein letzter bericht
ich gehe zurück nach deutschland
nun ist sie da die misere
jahrzehntelang hatte man menschen aus
dem ausland das gefühl gegeben nur
arbeitskraft zu sein
nur kleine teilchen die praktikabel sind
für wachstum und wohlstand
dafür erhält die schweiz nun die
quittung sie taumelt wie ein einsamer
planet das hier war einst eine
intensivstation für neugeborene
hochspezialisierte medizinische
versorgung basierend auf neuesten
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
das war einmal
auch im spital männedorf sorgt man sich
um die zukunft der hightech-medizin
gesundheitsökonom willy oggier sieht
schwarz für das schweizer
gesundheitswesen der schweiz ohne die
ausländische mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter ist schlicht nur duft tracht
holte mir die überhand bin früher mühsam
london bis ganz wichtiges wort schweiz
ruft wissen ich will mirka rohstoff hand
nämlich auf intelligenz auf innovation
auf know how und das bringen russland
ist die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
ganze welt mit und die kultur
institutionen des landes sind sie noch
finanzierbar
das zürcher opernhaus schließt mit
umgebaut zu einem spielcasino falls die
reichen überhaupt noch kommen wollen in
das verwaiste land das berner theater
jedoch spielt weiter kämpft ums
überleben
aber wie lange noch das ensemble von
maria stuart
alle nicht schweizer schauspieler
verlassen die bühne keine oper ohne chor
wie viele chordamen bleiben wenn die
sängerinnen mit migrationshintergrund
das land verlassen
das berner ballett probt othello ein
stück tanz über ausgrenzung
wie viele der tänzer der compagnie sind
aus der schweiz
niemand das öffentliche leben verödet
still ist es in den straßen geworden
grau ein einst blühendes land versinkt
in depression
ratlosigkeit herrscht bei den ökonomen
an der uni basel
gerade die wachstumsbranchen werden
darunter leiden dass es teilweise so
pharmaindustrie information
kommunikationstechnologien im
medizinischen bereich dort sind die
ausländer stark vertreten
da waren die lücke zu füllen und das
heißt also in diesen bereichen wird die
schweiz dann wenn es nicht darunter
leiden dass sie also kein zugriff auf
diese arbeitskräfte haben eine
krisensitzung jagt die andere
was tun wie kann man ausländerinnen und
ausländer bewegen im land zu bleiben
der bundesrat beauftragt die
kommunikationsagentur roth bekannt für
innovative idee sie sollen eine kampagne
entwickeln die sensibilisiert emotional
aufrüttelt und so die massenauswanderung
aufhalten soll
regula fecker und david schärer suche
nach ersten ideen und konfrontieren
migrantinnen und migranten mit einer
frage betrag wurde er leistet in der
schweiz willi rose in villa bosch mahle
dankeschön gehört
nein meistens fragt man mich warum ich
hier bin
bei einem verhör überrascht eigentlich
autofokus ist in top-form swissmedic
thailand russland entspannen dass es
beim sinnvoll durch die label oder bis
an krippen so stolz fotos stache könnte
natürlich sowie führen und ihnen zeigen
dass extrem stabile großen teil das sie
leistet das emotionale sätze zum
erreichen dass ich halt nicht am land
verboten der fülle
ein einfaches danke würde aus
gastarbeitern menschen machen
ein zeichen von respekt um die
massenauswanderung aufzuhalten und ein
bitte bitte bleibt